اه هيها ه هيها يمتد شارع صلاح الدين الذي
احتدم القتال على احد مفترقات مسافه 45
كيلومترا من بيت حنون شمال قطاع غزه الى
رفح جنوبها اما اسمه فذو شجون تمتد في
وجدان اهل هذه البلاد زمنا يبلغ طوله 800
سنه من مقاومتهم الغزو الاسرائيلي في
الوقت الراهن الى مقاومه اسلافهم الغزو
الصليبي قبل ثمانيه قرون واحد شارعين
رئيسين يتكون منهما قطاع غزه ثانيهما شارع
الرشيد ولا يزيد اجمالي المساحه بينهما
وحولهما في الجهات الاربعه عن
365 م مربع يقطنها نحو مليون و300 ال
فلسطيني في ظروف حصار خانق ومستمر فرضته
اسرائيل منذ 16 سنه وطعمته بخمس حروب
طاحنه اشدها التي يتفرج عليها العالم الان
وادت خلال 24 يوما مضت الى ما يزيد على
8000 شهيد وقرابه 20 الف جريح فضلا عن
تدمير 40% من المباني السكنيه وتشريد
مليون ونصف المليون نسمه عسكريا لا دلاله
استثنائيه لتمكن دبابات الاحتلال من
التوغل مسافه ثلاه كيلومترات وصولا الى
المفترق الذي وصلت اليه على شارع صلاح
الدين وان كان انسحابها منه تحت ضربات
المقاومه بعد نحو ساعه او اقل قد بدا
لافتا في نظر خبراء الحرب ذلك ان الموقع
الذي احتدم فيه القتال يوصف بانه خاصره
رخوه نظرا لعوامل عده منها تضاريسه
البسيطه وقله عدد سكانه وقربه الشديد الى
السياج الحدودي الفاصل بين
الجانبين وكان محللون قد اعتبروا ان
السيطره على جزء من شارع صلاح الدين اذا
تمكنت اسرائيل من فرضها فعلا ستؤدي الى
الفصل بين شمال قطاع غزه وجنوبه كجزء من
الحرب البريه التي تقول قوات الاحتلال
انها بدات جزئيا وتتعمق شيئا فشيئا بينما
يقول متحدثون باسم حركه حماس ان ما حدث
كان مجرد محاوله فاشله لرفع معنويات
الشارع الاسرائيلي واسترداد ثقته بجيشه
ليس من غير ذي دلاله عميقه في سياق الحدث
الجديد ان جوار هذه المنطقه من شارع صلاح
الدين كان موقعا
لمستوطنين التي سبق ان فككت ليرحل سكانها
قبل انسحاب جيش الاحتلال عام 2005 وهو
انسحاب جاء بعدما خابت امنيات قاده
اسرائيليين بان يستيقظوا ليجدوا غزه وقد
ابتلعها
البحر
بالعوده مره اخرى الى التاريخ المغلي في
القدم ينسب بعض المصادر تسميه الشارع
الغزي الشهير الى الناصر صلاح الدين قائد
الدوله الايوبيه الذي حرر القدس من
الصليبيين لكن هناك من يقول ايضا ان هذا
الشارع انشئ قبل ذلك بكثير بل انه احد
اقدم الشوارع في العالم وقد مرت عليه عبر
العصور جيوش مصر القديمه والاسكندر الاكبر
ونابليون
لدى زحفها للسيطره على بلاد الشام كانت
تلك امبراطوريات سادت هنا حقبا عابره في
الزمن ثم بادت يقول اهل غزه الفلسطينيون
وهم يواجهون مجددا ما يعتبرونها واحده من
اعتى حروب الاباده في
تاريخهم